les trains de fret devrait finalement
continuer à passer par le morvan ces
dernières années les lignes cerci
corbigny clamecy et nevers à rambouillet
était vieillissante et donc à terme
menacer 6 millions d'euros vont être
investis pour les rénover c est vraiment
de sécurité dont il s'agit travaux de
renouvellement de rails de traverse et
de ballast pour garantir la sécurité des
circulations
il n'est pas prévu aujourd'hui de de ré
ouvrir des lignes pour le fret mais en
tout cas la priorité c'est bien de de
préserver celles qui existent le
financement est partagé entre sncf
réseau état région département mais
aussi quatre groupes industriels qui
s'engage à hauteur de 2 millions d'euros
s'ils investissent c'est la garantie que
ces lignes seront utilisés et pour le
groupe soufflet qui transportent des
céréales cela sécurise la logistique les
lignes capillaire constitue un enjeu à
l'échelle locale et régionale
leurs noms maintien appliquerait une
hausse des coûts le camion étant plus
coûteux que le train sur les longues
distances
cet investissement permet de lutter
contre l'enclavement de la nièvre
mais pour le président du conseil
départemental il aura aussi des
répercussions en termes d'emploi et
d'environnement
ça fait moins de moins de camions sur la
route puis surtout en termes d'empreinte
carbone c'est s'améliore nettement les
choses et puis notamment par exemple il
ya de carrière qui sont desservis par
par ses lignes et c'est extrêmement
important
cicely n'existait pas très probablement
ses carrières disparaîtrait donc c'est
des emplois qui disparaîtront
les chantiers devraient débuter après
l'été et s'étaler jusqu'en 2023
en france le fret ne représente qu'à
peine 9 % du transport de marchandises
le gouvernement souhaite doubler ses
volumes dans les dix ans à venir